It's great to welcome Will Summer back to
the program, which is a tech reporter for
The Daily Beast, also author of the Right
Rechter newsletter on conservative media,
a great person to follow on Twitter.
I would also say.
Well, thanks.
Thanks for being back on.
Hey, thanks for having me.
So we've been we've been following and talking
about Q and on we've talked with Media Matters
Alex Kaplin about Q and on members who have
a real shot at being elected to Congress.
So we talked about Marjorie Taylor Greene
of Georgia, Colorado's Lauren Bobak.
There are others as well.
Kate, let's first start with with your assessment
of the strength of this as an actual political
movement.
Oh, yeah.
You know, I think Q On is really getting a
foothold within the GOP.
We saw a poll this week that said roughly
40 percent of Republican correspond.
Our respondents said that cute is a good thing.
You know, we've seen other polls suggesting
maybe around seven percent of people believe
in it.
So, you know, I mean, these are not it's not
a majority by any means.
But given how crazy their beliefs are, you
know, it's pretty concerning is I read an
interesting article by Greg Stanton and we
may be speaking to him at some point in the
future where he points out that.
Q And on ideology, to the extent that we can
call it an ideology, is really like rebranded
anti Semitic tropes, that there's a lot of
overlap with ideas from the Protocols of the
Elders of Zion and just a lot of the standard
tropes of white nationalism and anti-Semitism
that we've seen.
Do you agree?
And like what what portion is is made up of
that?
Yeah, sure.
It's so cute.
It's sort of like Scientology where when people
first get into it, like they don't tell you
kind of the wildest stuff.
So, you know, people get in and they'll say,
like, you know, don't you think, Jeffrey,
I've seen as bad as that people do.
And then they kind of get you in there.
And then when you're really into it, they
say what really KUNR is about people in banking
and Hollywood, which obviously kind of code
drinking children's blood.
So, you know, I mean, you get right into blood
libel right there.
So, you know, I did this.
I you know, Cunegonde really is about, you
know, alleging all these powerful Jewish people
are controlling the world.
So, you know, pretty anti-Semitic on its face.
There has been that in the last 48 hours.
It seems far less likely that this will happen.
But Donald Trump had been banking for political
reasons on a vaccine announcement probably
sometime in the next six weeks, which was
likely to be an emergency use authorization,
not a full approval from the FDA.
The idea being that he could sort of attach
himself to it and take credit for it up at
the same time there.
Q And on seems to be relatively anti vax.
Am I wrong about that?
So so I'm I'm seeing a very strange situation
where Trump has previously tweeted about vaccines
and autism.
He had to kind of be talked off the ledge
by Ben Carson during debates during the 2016
Republican primary.
Now he's sort of all in on a vaccine, and
yet this group seems very anti vax.
Yeah, it's an interesting contradiction.
You know, as you said, Trump has kind of promoted
anti vaccine stuff in the past.
But now in in KUNR on people often are very
anti vaccine KUNR or anti vaccine Facebook
groups can be sort of a gateway into Q and
on.
And so we've seen, especially during the pandemic,
we've seen interesting hughan on explode,
along with a lot of skepticism about vaccines.
And now you have Trump come out and say, well,
you know, the vaccine is really key to everything.
And so, I mean, there definitely is a clash
there.
I mean, you know, people have been saying,
you know, Bill Gates is going to put a microchip
in the vaccine.
Yes.
Yeah.
And suddenly Trump kind of has to turn these
people around on it.
When you look at the media foothold to the
extent that it exists for Q and on, are they
linked in any way to any particular media
outlets or publications?
And in particular, I'm interested about whether
there's a connection with O.J. and this sort
of like a poor man's Fox News, kind of a blend
between Fox News and a porn parody of sorts
that that Donald Trump has regularly called
on during his press briefings.
Yeah, you know, we see Cubin on its face is
so ridiculous that even conservative media
often wants to distance themselves from it.
But what they end up doing is sort of taking
ideas from Q and on and then sort of laundering
them, taking stripping the Cuban name off
of it and running with it.
In the case of oh, and initially they were
very antique Hewat on.
But you know, I just had a story this week
that they'd been selling the use of Q and
on emojis on their YouTube channel, including
one referring to JFK Jr. coming back to life.
So, you know, I mean, really there it seems
like they just decided to start profiting
from it.
Right.
On the David Pakman show, YouTube channel,
if you subscribe, you get various colored
show logos and yet on when you get Q and on
stuff.
That's certainly a different approach, I guess,
to to to sort of monetizing content.
Yeah, well, maybe you should consider, you
know, Oge that's like send Hillary to get
low all this.
Right.
I should I should look at.
Look at that direction.
So, OK.
Let's zoom out a little bit because you're
following a lot of these different movements.
What else is there right now that maybe our
audience is not super familiar with?
I mean, I think my audience is very familiar
with, you know, kind of your standard Trump's
talking points.
We've looked at video from rallies.
God is protecting me from the virus or the
virus itself is a hoax.
Sort of that wing which has anything Trump
says that they kind of repeat.
We've got this.
Q and on wing.
What other sort of subgroups are relevant
in the underbelly right now?
Yeah, well, you know, I mean, obviously we've
got these sort of violent groups like the
proud boys or the various kind of militias
that I think are really starting to merge
with Cuban on in some ways.
And really this is, you know, especially relevant
as we head into the election.
And these people are, you know, there's all
this kind of civil war type rhetoric.
And, you know, I think maybe you want the
most interesting ones, again, with some ties
to Cuba on is the growth of these conspiracy
theories in like wellness and like yoga, like
Instagram influencers.
I have not heard about this.
This is interesting.
Yeah.
So the typical Cuban unbeliever is, you know,
white, older, evangelical.
But what we're seeing is there's this group
called Save the Children.
And this is kind of a Cuban front group.
And they're having rallies with hundreds of
people across the world in different cities.
And they're they're sucking in a lot of moms
on Facebook.
You know, Cuba, mom.
And, you know, these various Instagram yoga
people who normally post about, you know,
eating yogurt and doing yoga and all this
stuff.
And then they'll just be like, you know, but
but we got to get to the bottom of what's
going on.
A comet, ping pong.
So, you know, it's it's disturbing, Stephanie.
I think it suggests that these conspiracy
theories can go beyond just the Trump base.
You mentioned the demographics of the typical
Q and on supporter.
One of the things we learned about 2016 was
that the rate of the dissemination of resharing
of fake news was significantly skewed not
just to the right, but to older folks.
And we could talk about sort of the reasons
why.
Q And On seems to have a significant younger
contingent that maybe wasn't there with some
of the predominant fake news stories of 2016,
is my impression, correct?
That's absolutely right.
And you know, one example just to pick one
is that.
Q And on and ticked higher excuse me.
And pizza gate are exploding on tech talk
with young people and they'll make these Tick-Tock
videos that say, like, you know, here's something
about John Podesta, you know, like you know
that now.
Is there anything that you can ascertain as
to why this is getting more pickup with younger
folks, whereas a lot of the 2016 stuff did
not?
Is it just that the technology now has changed
in such a way or the environment is different,
or is it a concerted effort?
You know, I think it's I think maybe the biggest
part is that the world just seems like it's
gotten a lot crazier, you know, and you have
these obviously you have the very real Eppstein
stuff that I think pulls people into these
conspiracy theories.
You know, you have the pandemic.
And so I think there's just a lot more people
who are kind of looking to get a grasp on
what's going on.
And unfortunately, they kind of fall down
these rabbit holes in.
In 2010, we saw the rise of the Tea Party
movement and a number of Tea Party candidates.
One Tea Party caucus was created in the House
of Representatives and then eventually the
Tea Party.
The caucus still exists, but some of it kind
of went away and some elements were integrated
into the Republican Party.
But there was never the Tea Party was not
associated with a presidential candidate in
the way that KUNR is associated with Trump.
So can you outline the likely paths where
you've got so you have Trump and then some
KUNR on candidates?
They all could win or they all might lose
or some combinations of the two.
What's the sort of path forward look like
depending on what happens in November?
Sure.
I mean, here's what we're looking at in terms
of like how many Cuban people are going to
be in Congress next year.
Right.
So we've got Marjorie Taylor Greene in Georgia
who you mentioned.
You know, she's a really Republican district.
She's a Republican.
So she's almost certain to win.
You know, Trump's endorsed her.
I think it's very interesting that the White
House has been very real.
They they just will not criticize.
Q And on which I think is another sign of
Cuban on power, you know, and in fact, when
a Republican lawmaker came out and did criticize
Q and on the Trump campaign attacked him.
So, you know, that's kind of a line is like
don't talk about Q and on and certainly not
in a negative way.
We've got Lauren Bobert in Colorado, House
candidate, kind of a battleground district.
She says, well, I don't believe in Q and on
anymore.
Oh, well, great.
You know, I mean, you know, if that you know,
I support Q and on I hope it's real and now
it's kind of backed away, but so she's maybe
got a toss up chance, you know, in I believe,
Oregon and in Delaware.
There are Republican Senate nominees who believed
in QAD on.
Probably not going to win, but still, you
know, out of 35 Senate races, we've got to
two with Q and unbelievers.
So, you know, I think the GOP is really failing
to stand up to this.
And so I think we can expect to see more of
it.
To what degree should the Democratic Party
engage with this, criticize it?
And what I mean, it's you know, there's often
a discussion about platforming versus ignoring
versus risk responsible platforming, as some
call it.
Do you have a sense of whether this has risen
to a point at which we need to hear more from
the left about it?
Well, you know, it's really hard to say.
I mean, as you say, on one hand, you don't
want maybe Joe Biden going out every day and
saying, you know, here's what he heard on
is, you know, because you're exposing certain
people to it.
On the other hand, I think certainly when
it comes to the media, you know, the cow has
left the barn.
I think in terms of not telling people like
and on are hoping it doesn't get bigger.
You know, we're talking about KUNR murders.
Q And on terrorism.
Q And on kidnaping.
And, you know, it's something I do think,
you know, we have to trust voters and the
audience to know what's going on.
Even, you know, even if it's very crazy.
If you look around the if you look around
the country and you see some of the different
groups that mean my take.
Well, maybe let's let's actually start there
to see if we're on the same page on this piece.
My take generally has been that Donald Trump
has not really generated new racism or xenophobia
or radicalism, but has made that which already
existed sort of more comfortable being public
about it.
Question one is, do you agree with that assessment
or has has Trump's presidency actually created
more of that?
Well, you know, it's really I think, you know,
I wouldn't want to suggest that Trump is,
you know, it kind of a unique character in
terms of, you know, racism.
On the other hand, I think in terms of conspiracy
theories, I think having a guy in the White
House who promotes this stuff obviously was
a big birther and legitimizes it.
I do think that kind of brings the GOP it
basically provides an opening, I think, for
these conspiracy theories to take over the
GOP and get more people from within.
So so I guess the question is, if Trump loses,
are we to expect that a lot of these groups
whose views are now much more in the open?
Are they going to go back underground?
In some sense, it doesn't eliminate the views.
It doesn't.
Radicalize.
But it would be, again, an environment where
they are less comfortable being public about
their views.
Or is the cat sort of out of the bag at this
point?
You know, it's hard to really predict what
happens.
But I do think that potentially if Trump loses,
you know, some people are anticipating, you
know, it's like the spell left.
The Cuban people don't believe it anymore.
I think instead what's going to happen is
that these people who have been so wrapped
up and basically convinced that Democrats
are like, you know, eating children and they're
Satanists and all this and that Trump's going
to solve it.
And then when he loses, they're going to say,
well, the deep state did it.
Now we have to take matters into our own hands.
So, you know, I feel like I could see you
really kunr of being integrated more into
the GOP potentially in a violent way.
One other thing specifically on the Q and
on Belief's, I wanted to ask about a lot of
that.
As you say, sometimes the gateway to Q and
on is Jeffrey Epstein related?
The more we know about Epstein, the more sort
of touch points there are with Donald Trump.
And there are even allegations that were made
in a lawsuit which have said that the lawsuit
has since been been pulled, but they were
allegations about joint sexual assault involving
Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein.
Is there no concern in your mind or discussion
among.
Q And on that the more they push this, that
it could actually implicate Donald Trump?
No, I mean, they have so much like cognitive
dissonance and rationalization when it comes
to Trump.
I mean, obviously, Trump, you know, appointed
the prosecutor who gave Epstein a sweetheart
deal to the cabinet.
You know, obviously there's videos of Trump
and Pepsi hanging out and kind of praising
women together.
And so instead, what they say is that, you
know, Trump was infiltrating Epstein's circle,
that by by appointing this prosecutor to the
cabinet, he was kind of drawing more attention
to this dirty deal and all this kind of stuff
that that's like a textbook example of the
unfalsifiable argument.
It's you know, there's an invisible tiger
in this room.
All right.
Well, let's, you know, let let's let's play
down some baby powder.
So as the invisible tiger walks around, it
will disturb the baby powder.
We'll know.
It's also a weightless, invisible tiger like
this.
You cannot possibly disabuse someone of those
beliefs and that maybe that's part.
But maybe that's by design, I guess.
Absolutely.
I mean, part of the beauty of the cute on
clues, the genius of it, is that even when
they make predictions, people will say, you
know, the prediction doesn't come true.
They'll say, well, maybe we just misread the
predictions we were wrong or that some maybe
Q was trying to throw off the deep stay, you
know, with some bad info.
And so really, this makes it really hard to
disabuse people of these notions.
And, you know, I hear all the time from people
who have lost family members or loved ones
to Q and on.
And, you know, it's really hard to get people
out of it.
We've been speaking with.
Will Summer tech reporter for The Daily Beast,
also author of the Right Rechter newsletter
on conservative media.
We'll always great speaking with you.
Absolutely.